hello freak look it's it's
exciting
the shit-talking is exciting yeah I like
when they make up afterwards that's what
I'm happy yeah I'll talk plenty
they fight and then they make up TJ and
Cody really didn't like I respect you
and then Cody's they can't respect them
but I everything I said was true
that guy
well when when TJ got in his face right
after the stoppage and was like touching
his face she gets all screaming out that
when you're dealing with a fight of that
magnitude and there's that much high
emotion passion there's gonna be a
little bit of that yeah but I never said
anybody do that before I never saw
anybody win by stoppage and then when
the guy gets up just out of it
TJ's in his face always been dreaming at
the top as long as with his mouth
touching his face like he was kissing it
like he's a baby bird and he was like
honest tippy-toes like this is a great
picture just shredded - an amazing
picture but that but again you know with
Cody had all that ammunition just the
week of like oh I didn't knock you out
Guu drops the video and I was like oh
I think one of the worst things
that happened for Cody is that he got
that knocked down do you think to do it
again are you know what you're saying in
practice or in no no no first right in
the first round look at that that is
insane I mean they're like oh geez yeah
lip-to-lip they're kissing
essentially kissing Cody is completely
out of it right he just got knocked out
cold I wasn't sure if he was out cold
but if you watch the stop it she stops
moving
hmm he got hit up was it good stop it he
came right back god I should stop
coughing right I love both those guys
man he came right back he got back up
like pretty quickly but I think that's
conditioning and just realizing that he
you know he came to he's a monster
TJ look out shreddies how the is he
gonna cut ten more pounds to go down to
fight Mighty Mouse mmm
do they did I catch weight to the belt
really matter they're gonna do it at to
125 Jenn I went to it when I talked to
TJ he swears he can make he goes all day
easily he might be able to - hey mighty
mouth who else you gonna fight well if
he gets a mic Dolce behind him or George
Lockhart or one of those weak cuts he
journalists yeah he has someone he does
he's a monster that's why it looks like
that right now here's some new guy that
he moved to California for if
you get a guy who's a weight cutting
expert I bet he could probably do it
oh he'll do it for sure he wanted to do
it original he was already making the
cut when he thought it was gonna happen
he's like he goes it's no problem he's
very disappointed in that fight and I
see his point but I also see mighty
Mouse's point mighty Mouse's point is
look what if TJ doesn't make the cut and
then I lose the fight what if he doesn't
make the weight and then I lose the
fight to him he's like that's a big deal
and I don't yeah and I don't set the
record yeah you wanted to set the record
the record was giant to him he want to
set the record in his weight class so he
said look I have one requirement let TJ
win a fight at 125 let him fight at 125
let him win and then I'll have him come
over we're gonna Jack that's after you
won that's real to man I mean that Sam
Ross that's some raw emotion we're
there how much there was someone they're
gonna fight three more times there's so
much talking go on and it was so
personal for these yeah boy it looked
bad when he got clipped you got clipped
at the end of the first round and it
looks like wow really bad he has a
piston for a right hand unbelievable
speed but then he came back real quick
like the beginning of the second round
he looked fine he looked amazing
he looked fine like didn't look
anything's wrong with him he started
throwing a lot more kicks and did you
see what uh TJ said because they're like
oh you're gonna give Cody and me that
rematch he goes hell no look at the fire
had to walk through to get back here
because it doesn't work like that's true
he was does not work like that to fight
what three guy had to wait over a year
fight three monsters in occur yeah by
the way he neutralized linacre -
that was one of them more in my opinion
one of the more fascinating fights
because I don't think there's another
guy in the division that would a
neutralize Linacre in that way and not
gotten hit agree I mean maybe Dominick
maybe Dominick but the thing about TJ
versus Dominick is TJ's more kick
oriented TJ can he's not the Dominic
doesn't have kicks but I think TJ has
more flexibilities more loose in the
outside keep TJ wins by head kick Yeah
right he had kicks guys he will he will
do all of the above you know he doesn't
have in any way a limited arsenal and I
don't know what they're gonna do next
but you know Dominick versus Jimmie
Rivera is a tough fight for Dom to me I
don't know Jimmy Rivera is a
nightmare
he's good people hey he's undefeated he
kind of mop the floor with you I favor
like he's no joke
fine under the radar but yeah he is and
his head is twice as big as either one
of the tank at that weight class and his
his low kick that low kick that everyone
is doing that below the calf kick or the
calf kick goddamn that is a debilitating
can that dudes my Dark Horse no one's
really talking on my god yeah you know
when I was in the martial arts in New
York in like that area
Tiger Schulman had like a whole chain of
karate schools and I'm sure they did
competitions and stuff I'm pretty sure
but no one ever would have thought they
would become like a powerhouse for MMA
but they've had quite a few like really
talented fighters there
well they had that kid with the green
hair the his name bantamweight
gentleman oh I didn't talking
about guy can I do I didn't stop he
stopped fighting they did it just dipped
out right now they come out they have
that kid it's gonna be a lot of they
have that can do this I can't remember
this either sorry to butcher this but oh
yeah we're at one of his other guys had
this crazy choke that uh we had to like
go over in the gym and try to figure out
yes yes garden Oh yep sorry loose
there's Gus now he was one of my favs oh
dude he's a he's a tiger showman guy
pretty sure and then there's been a few
other guys too
[Applause]
[Music]